you absolutely can sell something for a
million dollars if you go to an
e-commerce store and they're doing a
hundred million dollars a year and you
say hey if I can increase your
conversion across your entire site
rewrite your emails redo your landing
pages
Etc and I can get you a five percent
lift site-wide can I get one percent of
that so you make them an extra five
million a year and you get one do you
think you can do that yes why are you
gonna be able to do so much not because
of you but because of who they are and
you're like I don't know how to do that
that's fine but accept that you don't
know how to do that and then say I want
to learn how to do that and then go get
the skill of doing that and then you can
go sell it you can't say that you don't
have the money and that's why you can't
make money that's how you make a million
dollars like real talk